شكرا للزميله فاطمه فهد اهلا بكم في هذه
الساعه الجديده من تغطيتنا المستمره
للاحداث في السودان في يومها الثالث عشر
اخر التطورات تمثلت بهدنه هشه دخلت يومها
الثالثه والاخير وسط مساء لتمديدها
الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه ياتي هذا مع اعلان
نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع عدد القتلى
المدني جراء الاشتباكات الى 3 اشخاص
بالاضافه لتسجيل اكثر من 1800 حاله اصابه
بين المدنيين منذ بدايه الاشتباكات اهلا
بكم الى ساعه من الاخبار لتغطيه
الشان السوداني في يومه الثالثه عشر
[موسيقى]
اذا اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش بشن
هجوم ضد قواتها في معسكر بمنطقه كافوري في
الخرطوم بحري بالطيران والمدفعيه وقالت في
بيانها انه تم التصدي للهجوم والسيطره على
اعتاد عسكري وقالت ايضا ان الجيش يواصل شن
هجمات على معسكراته رغم الهدنه الانسانيه
افاد مراسل العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع خلال
الساعات الاخيره غربا وجنوب مدينه ام
درمان بولايه الخرطوم اوضح مراسلنا ان
الاشتباكات العنيفه التي شهدتها المنطقه
القريبه من سوق ليبيا غربا المدينه وبان
الجيش السوداني دفع بتعزيزات عسكريه عبر
شارع النيل باتجاه جسر شنبات امام مدينه
الخرطوم بحري فشهدت اشتباكات بين الطرفين
وان كانت بوتيره اقل حده من الاشتباكات في
ام درمان
اظهرت صور خاصه للعربيه الخلوه التام
لشارع النيل ام درمان صباح اليوم من
السيارات نشاهد
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهرت صور متداوله على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تحركا لقوات كبيره من الجيش الى
الخرطوم وافادت مصادر بان تلك القوه تحركت
من ولايات الجزيره ونير الابيض ونهر النيل
[موسيقى]
قتلوا في اشتباكات في ولايه ديرف اوضحها
ان اشتباكات في مدينه الجنينه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع تحولت الى قتال قبلي ادى
الى مقتل العشرات اضاف المصدر الصحفي
للعربيه ان الاشتباكات وقعت بين قبيله
المساريت والقبائل العربيه في الجنينه غرب
دارفور من جهتها اعلنت القبائل العربيه في
بيان وقفه اطلاق النار فورا داعيه
منسوبيها كافه لضبط النفس والالتزام
الفوري بذلك
ايضا في ظل الاستمرار للاشتباكات بين
المكونين العسكريين في السودان اكدت نقابه
اطباء السودان ان ثلاثه اطفال لقوا حتفهم
في مدينه الابيض بشمال كردوفان نتيجه في
جاري قذيفه وقالت ان عدد القتلى ارتفع الى
303 اشخاص اثر استمرار تبادل اطلاق النار
المستمر في حين سجلت النقابه اصابات بلغت
1848 حاله بين المدنيين منذ بدايه الصراع
موضحه ان العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله في هذه الاحصائيه لعدم تمكنها من
الوصول للمستشفيات بسبب صعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
قال عضو مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي لحل
الازمه في السودان للعربيه ان الطرفي
النزاع وفقاء على مبادره للتسويق قدمها
رئيس جزر القمر تتضمن وقفا دائما لاطلاق
النار واكد الجيش السوداني تسل مقائد
القوات المسلحه عبد الفتاح البرهان مبادره
منظمه ايجاد وموافقته عليها مبدئيا وتتضمن
المبادره تمديد الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه كما
تنص على افاده ممثلين للجيش والدعم السريع
الى جوبا لمناقشتها
[موسيقى]
الجهتين استطاع ايضا ان يعرض عليهما
خريطه عمل هي في الحقيقه تهدف الى
دعوه الجهات المعنيه بالوضع السوداني الى
طاوله الحوار
وكذلك
دعوه المجتمع الدولي الى ان يقفوا على
جانب الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل ايجاد حل
طريقي
الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه ايجاد
هي منظمه شبه اقليميه في افريقيا
تاسست عام
1996 وتتخذ من جيبوت مقرا لها تضم كلا من
اثيوبيا كينيا اوغندا الصومال جيبوتي
اريتريا السودان جنوب السودان
ايجاد سلمت قائد القوات المسلحه السودانيه
مبادره للسلام ويقول الجيش السوداني
المبادره تتضمن تمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه
المبادره تنص على افاده ممثلين الجيش
والدعم السريع الى جوبا لمناقشتها
البرهان وافق مبدئيا على مبادره منظمه
الامريكيه ينضموا الينا الباحث السياسي
الدكتور صلاح البشير دكتور صلاح مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه
يعني اولا ما الذي نصت عليه بشكل اساسي
هذه المبادره مبادره الايجاد وكيف تقراها
قبل ذلك
مرحبا بالعربيه
وبمنسوبيها ومرحبا
بمشاهديها اهلا بك الايجاد
هي
مؤسسه او منظمه
ضعيفه المستوى من حيث التاثير
على الدول الافريقيه المشاركه فيها
[موسيقى]
ضمت موضوعين اساسيين هو
اولا ان مد الهدنه ل 72 ساعه اخرى حتى
يتمكن الجميع من القيم بواجباتهم في ظل
ظروف
عسكريه افضل انشئه تعني وهو ان يلتقي
مسؤولا من كلا الطرفين في
غالبا
يباع حاضره السودان الجنوبي او جنوب
السودان
وان يجلس وفقا
ما يمكن ان يضعه ثلاث من رؤساء دول
الايجاد مثل التصور لحل هذه الازمه هذه
اهم
الدين في هذا الامر طيب دكتور اذا كان
اساس هذه
المبادره هي الهدنه
يعني هناك من يقول بان الهدن الهدن
السابقه لم تصمد فشلت تم اختراقها اكثر من
مره فبالتالي اساس هذه المبادره لا يمكن
تنفيذه على الارض فبالتالي هي غير مكتمله
الى حد كبير انا اتفق مع هذه المقوله
باعتبار ان ما سبق لا
يقدم ما يفيد بان هذه الهدنه ستنجح السبب
الاساسي هو محاوله الاستفاده من هذه
الهدنه لترتيب الاوضاع العسكريه على الارض
خاصه من قبل الدعم السريع لانه الدعم
السريع الان يفتقد الى الاتصالات ويفتقد
الى
من حيث الذخيره والوقود وحتى
قدرته على
تغذيه
جنود الدعم السريع وهم يعملون الان بدون
اتصالات وبالتالي هم يحتاجون الى هذه
المساله في
التحرك في الاتصال هذا التحرك يفضي الى
تحرك الاسلحه من مكان لمكان لا يقبله
الجيش لانه وجود تعزيزات جديده
سيطيل من امد الحرب
القمع يا دكتور صلاح ساعود اليك مره اخرى
للحديث بشكل موسع حول هذه المبادره وحول
ايضا مستقبل الحلول السياسيه في ضمن تشهده
السودان من مدينه ايضا بورتسودان ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار
مرحبا بك معي كيف هي الصوره لديك كيف
يمكنك وصفها ايضا
لك
تحيه المستمره لقناه العربيه من بورسودان
ومن جده ومن مختلف المعابر لنقل حيثيات
وتداعيات ازمه الصراع في السودان صور الان
تتحدث عن نفسها
52 من ممثلي البعثات الدبلوماسيه الان في
طريقهم الى
الباخره الملكه الجبيل التابعه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه الان يغادرون ميناء
بورسودان في هذا المربط وهذا المرسى
الرئيسي بميناء بورسودان هم الان في
طريقهم مباشره عبر هذه القطعه البحريه الى
الباخره الرئيسه السعوديه التي ستقلهم بعد
قليل الى ميناء جده هذه العمليه الان
مستمره 52 من اثنتي عشره دوله افريقيه
وعربيه واوروبيه وامريكيه وصلوا قبل يومين
الى بورسودان استكملوا كافه الاجراءات
بالتنسيق مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
التي سيرت عديد القطع البحريه التي تصل
تباعا منذ الحادي والعشرين من هذا الشهر
الى ميناء بورسودان تنسق بصوره محكمه مع
الجيش السوداني ومع مختلف الوحدات
والهيئات هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر التي
لجان ولائيه واتحاديه للتعاطي والتعامل مع
هذه العمليه الكبرى عمليه الاجلاء الان
هؤلاء الممثلون للبعثات الدبلوماسيه
ورعايا عدد من الدول في طريقهم الان الى
الملكه الجبيل للمغادره بعد قليل كما
ذكرنا في اطار استكمال عمليات اجلاء رعايه
دول الاوروبيه والعربيه والاسيويه من
مختلف الدول الى السودان
طيب
السؤال ايضا كذلك النزار عن السفن العمليه
يعني عذرا صوتك انقطع فبالتالي يعني اعتقد
بانك انتهيت من الاجابه ان كان تضيف تفضل
نزار
نعم اشير الى ان عدد من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه شرعت قبل يومين في التنسيق
المباشر مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهذا
التنسيق للسعوديه يتم ايضا باحكام مع
الجيش السوداني الذي شكل اللجنتين لجنه
للاجراء البحري ولجنه للاجلاء عبر الطيران
من مطار بورسودان الدولي الان هذه القطعه
البحريه التي رست قبل قليل هنا في ميناء
بورسودان ستتحرك الان صوبه
المربط الذي توجد به الملكه الجبيل
لابحار نحو المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذه
العمليه كما ذكرنا باشراف من الجيش
وبتنسيق ايضا من قوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه التي
وصلت الى هذه المنطقه خلال الايام الماضيه
باشراف من الضباط البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه
باشراف ايضا من ضباط من الجيش السعودي هذه
العمليه تمضي بسلاسه نحن الان نتحدث عن
اكثر من 2500 تم اجلائهم عبر البحر
بالتنسيق مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تحركوا منذ الحادي والعشرين من هذا الشهر
وصلوا الى ميناء جده في عمليه مستمره
تباعا بتنسيق مشترك باحكام بين مختلف
اللجان الفنيه والاداريه لاستكمال هذه
العمليه عمليه الاجلاء من السودان الى
مختلف الدول الاوروبيه والعربيه اللجان
الفنيه والاداريه ايضا كيف يتم التنسيق
يعني بينها البين في اعمالها يعني لترتيب
امور
اللاجئين لترتيب ايضا حتى تخريس امور
السفر لهم ايضا والتاكد والتثبت من
الوثائق نزار
نعم اللجان العديده هي لجان مشتركه لجان
حصر الجوازات ولجان التاكد من الهويه
ولجان التاكد والاستوثاق من الاوراق
الثبوتيه كل هذه اللجان الان تتحكم فيها
لجنه عليا
انقطع الاتصال ولكن ساكمل هذه الفكره
اللجنه عليا هي التي تشرف وتنسق مع كل
اللجان الفنيه والصحيه ولجنه الجوازات
ولجنه الحصر حتى تمضي هذه العمليه وفق
الثلاثه التي بدات بها منذ الحادي
والعشرين من هذا الشهر اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات على الصوره التي
نقلتها لنا من ميناء بورد سودان مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي
اكد الجيش السوداني انه لا يوجد تفاوض مع
قوات الدعم السريع سواء في جنوب السودان
او في اي دوله اخرى في الوقت الحالي واكد
الجيش السوداني ان المعركه الان لحسم ما
وصفه بتفلت قوات الدعم السريع ودحرها من
الخرطوم وفي تصريحاته للعربيه اوضح الجيش
السوداني انا رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان لن يسافر لدوله اخرى للقاء
من وصفه بقائد التمرد في اشاره الى قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
ونبقى في بورتسودان من هناك يلتحق بنا
الصحفي عبد القادر باكاش عبد القادر مرحبا
بك معي ما هي اخر المعلومات والارقام ايضا
المتوفره لديك حول من تم اجلائهم من بورت
سودان
باتجاهات مختلفه الى خارج السودان
[موسيقى]
16 ابريل وهناك نشره صدرت من المكتب
الاقليمي للطيران المدني الدولي بالقاهره
يوم 16
للطيارين السودانيين
حتى 30 ابريل
من غير المعروف هل سيتم في 30 ابريل فتحه
المطار امام الطيران المدني ام لا لكن
الان المطار مغلق تماما المطار بورسودان
الدولي ممكن حمام حركه الطيران المدني
وجميع الطائرات التي استقبلها المطار
حوالي 25 رحله تقريبا لعدد كبير من الدول
تم استقبالها وهي يعني استقبل الطائرات
سعوديه واردنيه ومغربيه والجزائريه وكوريه
ويابانيه وامريكيه ومجاريه وارابيه وغيرها
منذ الماضي عمليات الاجلاء التمضي بشكل
ممتزم جوا وظهرا
وهناك يعني قدوم متواصل من
سوبي منظمات
الامميه والمنظمات الانسانيه الى مدينه
بورسودان جميع
الفنادق وشقق الفندقيه مشغوله تماما الان
وهناك مجهودات تتم من حكومه ولايه البحر
الاحمر
الو اسمعك اسمعك عبد القادر تفضل اكمل
لجنه من حكومه ولايه البحر الاحمر بالامس
تم عقد الاجتماعي لجنه الامني بالولايه
للوقوف على الوضع الامني ووضع مزيد من
الترتيبات الامنيه واليوم الاقتصاديه
لحكومه ولايه البحر الاحمر
للاطمئنان على موقف القدمات والمخزون
الاستراتيجي للخدمات المتوفره وضمان
استدامه الخدمات وعدم وجود اي نقص او
استغلال القادمين في الاسعار هناك رقابه
مشدده ستتم على جميع المرحله التجاريه
ولاسهاب الشقق الفندقيه حتى لا يتم
استغلال الذين
يفقدون الى ولايه
خلال اليومين الماضيه خلال اليومين
وخادمين عمليات الاجلاء متواصله وتتم
بتنسيق مباشر بين الحكومتين السعوديه
والسودانيه السعوديه هي القبله الاولى
لتسعين في المئه من القادمين من رعايه هذه
الدول ومن المنظمات باعتبار ان المملكه
الان هي الاقدر
والاكثر كرما في استضافه هؤلاء القادمين
وهي التي تقوم بتسهيل الاجراءات لهم مجانا
الى الموانع السعوديه
طيب ممتاز عبد القادر كم عدد الطائرات
التي استقبلها مطار بورتسودان اليوم ان
كان من عدد محدد
اليوم استقبل ثلاثه طائرات منذ هذا الماضي
استقبل 25 دائره ممتاز طيب المواطنون
السودانيون هل عادوها وصلوا الى ميناء
ومن المتوقع يستقبل المزيد من التائرات
خلال نهار اليوم لان عمليات الاجلاء
المتواصله والطيران الحربي الطلباته ترد
بشكل مباشر للمطار دون اخطار مسبق
كنت اسال عن المواطنون السودانيون هل عاد
اي منهم ووصل الى بورتسودان
نعم برشلونه تستقبل اهداف كبيره من
السودانيين لكن اغلب السودانيين الذين
ياتون الى برشلونه هم
لديهم
لبرسودان لذلك يقيمون في الاحياء جويهم
وهناك ايضا خطه من حكومه الولايه
للتجهيز بعد المدارس وانشاء معسكرات للذين
ليست لديهم اهالي لكن اغلب يعني لم نشاهد
اي اقتزاز في الشوارع او منطقه الان اغلب
السودانيين الذين وصلوا نزلوا في اماكن
وتم يعني لوائهم مع ذويهم حكومه الولايه
ترتب لاولاد معسكرات لكن لا هوجا حتى الان
لاقامه معسكر للايواء لان المدينه تبعد عن
العاصمه واغلب السودانيين الذين يفيدون
اليها هم اما ان يكون لديهم اهل في
بورسودان او يكونوا قاصدين الخروج مهرا من
السودان الى وجهات اخرى باعتبار بعضهم
حملت جوازات مزدوجه جنسيات اوروبيه وغيرها
طيب قبل قليل ذكرت بان الولايه او حاكم
ولايه البحر الاحمر
في سبل تامين الخدمات الاساسيه والمحافظه
ايضا حتى ربما على استقرار الاسعار في هذه
الولايه ما هو وضع هذه الخدمات الاساسيه
الان بما يخص المواد الغذائيه الادويه
وغيرها والايواء ايضا كذلك وهل هناك ايضا
اذا سمحت لعبد القادر زياده في اسعارها
خلال هذه الفتره وازمه 13 يوما
حتى الان المخزون من السلع الاستراتيجيه
المتوفر مخزون كافي لكميات كبيره لان
المدينه اصلا
وتستقبل كميات طول
السلعه الاستراتيجيه وايضا المخزون من
المحروقات ايضا كافيه لهادات كبيره لم
نلاحظتها الان اي ازمه لا في الخدمات ولا
في السلع الميشيه وفي المحروقات الان
العمليه يتم بشكل مباشر لكن هناك رقابه
امنيه حتى لا تتصرف خاصه المحروقات لاماكن
اوكرانيا لذلك الان تم يعني اجراءات
ولائيه للاشراف المباشر على كل هذه
الخدمات اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل التي وفيتنا بها من
بورتسودان الصحفي عبد القادر بكرش
اكد عروه الصادق عضو حزب الامه القومي في
لقاء مع العربيه ان فلول النظام السابق
حشدوا لهذه الحرب وانهم يفضلون حرق
السودان على البقاء خارج الحكم
انا اقول بحقائق يعلمها الجنرال محمد
حمدان
الجنرال برهان ان الفلول تحركوا منذ نهايه
يناير المنصرم لتاجيج الوضع وحشدوا لذلك
كافه قوات الاحتياطي اللي هي الدفاع
الشعبي من اسلامي يقولون النظام السابق
وهيئه العمليات حشدوها في الخرطوم بقوام
ما يزيد عن
146 بواسطه جنرالات من المؤسستين
عزياء واسلحه لصالح انطلاع هذه المعركه
التي كان مقررا لها ان تندلع في 19 فبراير
للمصري مخاطبنا بذلك الجنرال وجراى بوساطه
حميده قادت حزب الامه القومي وبعد قاده
الحريه والتغيير لخفض التوتر وايقاف هذا
العبث الذي كان يمكن ان يندلع في ذلك
الوقت هؤلاء اما ان يجلسوا على سده الحكم
في البلاد او ان يجلسوا على ركام البلاد
ليس لهم خيار سوى ذلك
معروض صادق القوات المسلحه بانها تضم في
صفوفها ضباطا يتبعون لتنظيم الاخواني
وبلول النظام السابق
من قوات المسلحه هنالك جنرالات يتبعون
للتنظيم ويعتمرون بامر الفريق
امر التنظيم اخواني وكذلك الدعم السريع
استوعب عدد كبير جدا من الجنرالات التنظيم
المحلول ومن مصرحين هيئه العمليات في فتره
من الفترات ان كان هو في يوم من الايام
رئيس المؤتمر الوطني
مؤكدماء ولكن بحديث المقروء انهم حاج الى
الثوره وانه تجرد من الاائق مع التنظيم
المباد فهو امر اخر ولكن الان هو في كماشه
التنظيم المباد وفي كماشه دينارات التنظيم
المحلول وهو امر سيودي به الى الدروه هذا
ما قلته له ان عاد التنظيم المحلول لن
يكون مصيرك سجين كوبر سينكوبر سنكون نحن
السياسيين وامتى سيكون مصيرك الدين و
سيصيبونك بطلقه في جبهتك فنحن نحتاج الان
الى اخراج البلاد واخراجهما منعاونه
عروه الصادق عضو حزب الامه القومي عبر
ايضا في لقاء مع العربي عن ماخذ على قوات
الدعم السريع التي تتواجد داخل المدن وان
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وقع في
المحظور
نحن بل لنا ماخذ على هذه القوات ونحن نمنا
من صيادها ما ناله العصبه لقوه انا ما
اخذت الحاليه والانيه هي التدرس بالمدن
داخل المدن والصراع داخل المدن هذا يجب ان
ينتهي باعجل ما تيسر لان هذا الامر راينا
هو الذي برر للجيش قصف المدن
وقصف الامور يجب ان تتوقف السيد محمد
حمدان اقولها له وقلت له مرارا من تكرارا
ان لا يستفز ولا يستثار سيستفزك
الاسلاميونك الى حرب وان الصراع في
السودان لا يحل بالبندقيه والديمقراطيه لا
يؤتى بها بالبندقيه قال ووعد بانه لن ينجر
اليها ولكن للاسف وقع في المحظور الان هما
اذا اراد الذهاب لم يسمح لهما التنظيم
المحلول للذهاب الى هنا مره اخرى الى
ولايه ميريلاندا الامريكيه وينضم الينا من
هناك الباحث السيسي دكتور صلاح البشير
دكتور صلاح مرحبا بانضمامك الينا مره اخرى
البرهان قال بانه لن يسافر الى اي دوله
اخرى للقاء محمد حمدان دقلو وهو طبعا من
وصفه بقائد التمرد هل هذا رفض غير مباشر
من البرهان لمبادره الايجاد
الحقيقه هذا رفض مباشر
لمبادره الايجاد لانه مبادره الايجاد لا
تحمل من الضغوط مع تدفع طرفان الى الجلوس
للمفاوضات هذه الناحيه الناحيه الاخرى
والمهمه جدا الذي يحصل عنها البعض هو
الموقف على الارض الموقف العسكري على
الارض فاميل
كفه الصراع باتجاه احدهما تمنع قيام اي
نوع من انواع المفاوضات المباشره خاصه اذا
كان هنالك
غلبه عسكريه يقدر يحسبها العسكريون
بطريقتهم الخاصه
ويدركون
بالضغط على الجانب الاخر ربما يكون النصر
حليفهم قريبا وبالتالي هذا ما تفتقده
الافاد والايجاد خاصه انها لا تملك
ما يمكنها من الضغط على الطرفين
باي وسيله من الوسائل ما الذي يجب ان
تملكه
الايجاد او اي منظمه اخرى او اي حتى جهات
اقليميه يمكن ان تجمع طرفي هذه الازمه ما
هي اوراق الضغط التي يجب ان تملكها على اي
من طرفي هذه الازمه
العلاقات والمصالح المباشره ندرك مثلا على
المستوى الاقليمي ان هنالك
علاقه قويه بين الجيش كمؤسسه
برئاسه البرهان
الحكومه المصريه ممثله في السيسي في
الرئيس السيسي الذي يمثل الجانب العسكري
ايضا فلهم لغه مشتركه ولهم تعاون خلال هذه
الفتره
السابقه في الاربع سنوات السابقه الدوله
الامارات العربيه ايضا لديها
كثير جدا جدا من نقاط الضغط التي تستطيع
ان تدفع
الجنرال حميتي للجلوس والتفاوض
السعوديه تملك امكانيه الضغط عليهما
بشكل مشترك هي عندها علاقات جيده جدا مع
الجيش السوداني ممثلا في البرهان والحكومه
السابقه وايضا مع
الجنر
وبالتالي تغلب هذه المجموعه بالاضافه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه المجموعه
كونت الان
رباعيه تريد ان تقدم حلا لكي يجلس الطرفان
لاجل ايقاف هذه الحرب اما الحديث عن
الايجاد التي هي في الترتيب
الرسمي اقل من الاتحاد الافريقي اقل من
الامن والسلامه الافريقي لا اتصور انها
يعني ان تذهب بعيدا يعني الحديث عن دور
وعن الاتحاد الافريقي دكتور صلاح السؤال
هو عن غياب دور الاتحاد الافريقي اليوم في
محاوله
ايجاد يعني اي حلول ممكن اولا ان تجمع
طرفي الازمه على الاقل تثبيت الهدنه في
السودان برايك هل تراجع دور الاتحاد
الافريقي داخل السودان
نعم لانه الاتحاد الافريقي يعتمد على وجود
مدنيين يفهمون في
الحركه السياسي السياسي باكثر من الحراك
العسكريه
والحرب الدائره حاليا في الخرطوم تحديدا
هي حرب عسكريه بحته بين ما كان يسمى
بالمكون العسكري بساقيه الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع وكلنا يذكر حديث البرهان
بان
الدعم السريع قد ولد من رحمه الجيش في ذلك
الوقت كان
واحد جسما واحدا هذا الجسم الواحد يعمل ضد
المدنيين
ويكبس على الحراكه السياسي بحيث لا يتحرك
بشكل او باخر العسكر
ربما يفهمون بعض الشيء في السياسه ولكن
ليس لديهم حل سواء كانوا من الجيش او غير
ذلك لكن السودانيين الان
بشكل عام في كل السودان
عليهم او من الواجب عليهم الوقوف مع الجيش
السوداني ضد
ماليشيا
الدعم السريع لانها في النهايه هذا الجيش
السوداني يمثل
مؤسسه وطنيه دفع السودانيون دماءهم لاجلها
منذ قبل الحرب العالميه الاولى الان
نحن امام فرقه متمرده تتبع
لعائله ثم لقبيله وتريد ان تفرض سيطرتها
على السودان
توصيف الصحيح لما يحدث الان
ومحاوله الاستيلاء للسلطه على السلطه
دكتور صلاح
كذلك السؤال فيما يخص الدعم الس ريع لماذا
لم يعلق او لم يجب على هذه المبادره
مبادره الايجاد سواء بالقبول قبول هذه
المبادره او برفضها ايضا حتى كذلك
اعتقد ان المشكله في الدعم السريعي هو
مشكله اتصال اذا اعتبرنا انه هذه حرب فان
مجلس الحرب في الدعم السريع غير قادر على
الجلوس
للمناقشه اي من الحلول المطروحه حتى اذا
كانت حلا عسكريا هما الان
مشتتون غير قادرين على غير قادرين على
التواصل بحيث انه يكون هنالك قرارات واضحه
جدا
وذلك واضح كان منذ اليوم الثالث لهذه
الحرب انه مع مرور هذه الحرب الى الامام
ستضعف قدرات الدعم السريع في التواصل وان
يكون لحمه واحده الان هنالك اكثر من جهه
لا تستطيع ان تعرف ماذا في اثاني
الجهات الاخرى والجهات العليا على مستوى
الجنود لا يدري كل مجموعه تعمل
لوحدها دون اي تنسيق وده ما يصاقم الامر
بالنسبه للدعم السريع وما يفاقم الامر
بالنسبه للحرب نفسها اشكرك جزيل الشكر
ساعود اليك طبعا دكتور صلاح مره اخرى مره
اخرى طبعا لاستكمال
الحديث عن الشان السوداني هذه صور مباشره
مشاهدينا من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
كما نشاهد الان مراسل العربيه اسفل الشاشه
في هذا الخبر وشريط الاخبار العاجله يقول
بان طيران الجيش شن غارات على مواقع للدعم
السريع بمحيط القياده العامه اضاف كذلك
ايضا بان هناك دوي لاطلاق مضادات ارضيه
تابعه للدعم السريع في محيط القياده
العامه بالعاصمه السودانيه
عفوا بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ايضا
طيران الجيش كما ننقل عن مراسل العربيه
بانه شن غارات على مواقع للدعم السريع
بمحيط القياده العامه الدعم السريع بدوره
كان قد اكد بان الجيش هاجم قوته في منطقه
كفوري بالخرطوم بحري بالطيران والمدفعيه
مراسل العربيه يؤكد بان الطيران الجيش
استهدف تمركزات للدعم السريع في منطقه
صالحه بام درمان اذا الجيش يستهدف تمركزات
للدعم السريع في منطقه صالحه
باندرمان كل هذه الانباء تاتي والسودان
يعني يعيش هدره وصفت بانها هدنه هشه تم
اختراقها في اكثر من مناسبه الان مراسله
العربيه يؤكد بان طيران الجيش
استهدف
تمركز للدعم السريع في منطقه صالحه
هذه
ايضا كل الاخبار التي تاتي من الخرطوم حتى
اللحظه وهذه الصوره مباشره امامنا للسودان
والتي تعيش الحرب في يومها الثالثه عشر
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد وربما اعمده الدخان
الكثيفه غطت سماء
العاصمه منذ اسبوعين ولا زالت اعمده
الدخان والسيله اللهب اذا في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم واضحه امام العيان
يصل الى مصر الالاف من السودانيين كل يوم
عبر الطريق البريه هربا من الاحداث في
بلادهم ملايين السودانيين يعيشون في مصر
ومن النازحين من يستقروا في اسوان اقرب
المدن المصريه للحدود وللتقافه السودانيه
ومنهم من يتوجه لمدن اخرى خاصه القاهره في
كان في الاقارب او المعارف مراسل العربيه
التقى احدى العائلات الفاره من السودان
ونقل قصتها في سياق هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
عندنا العيش في المخابز ما في الغاز ما في
كهرباء ما في مويه ما في يعني الحياه
انعدمت تماما يعني في اي لحظه نحن ممكن
نضيعوا مني اما الرحله الطويله التي
استغرقت ثلاثه ايام فكانت خليطه من المشقه
والخوف في الطريق ماذا
ياكلوا عايزين يشربوا عايزين يناموا
مرتاحين فهمته وبعدين صوت النار العلب
يخافوا في الايام العاديه غير الحرب كان
في نهر
يعني انت بتيجي ماشي بالعربيه فين في في
ناس بيموت وكده في الطريق يعني هسه احنا
لما جاي قلبنا في يدنا في الرعب
يعني
في الشوارع ويجر رصاص المباني بتوعه
والحريق لا نحن محتاجين دكتور نفساني
والله العظيم يعني انا ما اعرف انا ما
قريت الملف لكن الوضع
ممدوح يعني مستحيل انك تشوف يعني انت في
لحظه وانت قاعد في بيتك مطمئن فجاه تلقى
نفسك جيت لاجئ اخيرا تم لم شمل الاسره بعد
عناء تركوه وراء ظهورهم مع ما تركوه من
امتعه في بيتهم المغلق في كسلا فهم جاءوا
باقل القليل من الملابس ويشعرون بعدم
الثقه في ان محنتهم ستنتهي قريبا تامر
نصرت العربيه القاهره
معلمين الحدود المصريه السودانيه مراسل
العربيه احمد عثمان احمد مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه احمد كنت يعني منذ يوم امس في
معبر تصف لنا المشهد من هناك اليوم كيف هي
الصوره في الحدود المصريه السودانيه ما
الذي يمكن ان تضيفه ايضا
مشابه الى حد كبير يعني حتى الان هناك
يعني خروج
للعالقين من الجانب السوداني هناك تفاوت
في هذا الخروج وايضا في الاعداد من قبل
القادمين من السودان سواء من المصريين او
من السودانيين او من الاجانب ربما في فتره
الاخيره اغلب من يخرجون من المعبر هم من
السودانيين ربما المشهد الابرز الذي يتحدث
عنه الجميع الان هو متعلق بالفتره الطويله
التي تستغرقها عمليات الخروج هذه الفتره
الطويله ربما كانت هي الحديث الابرز في
السلايم الذين يؤكدون بان يعني هناك اطاله
في الوقت ولكن على الجانب الاخر السلطات
المصريه ايضا تقول بانها تزيد تحاول ان
تزيد من الموظفين العاملين في المعبر وكما
تحدثنا هناك دائما يعني اصرار بان يكون
هناك ت ان يكون هناك مراجعه امنيه للبضائع
لكل من يخرج من المعبر خلال الايام
المقبله ولكن على كل الاحوال
العملانين على قدم وساق وفي نفس الاطار
يخرجون من خلال هذا المعبر ليتوجهون الى
اسوان الاغلبيه منهم تتوجه الى عثمان الى
يعني مركز للحافلات في جنوب اسوان ثم
ينتقلون الى وسط المدينه اخرون ياخذون
حافلات مباشره الى القاهره ايضا الدوله
المصريه حريصه على تقديم كل الدعم من خلال
قرارات
منها على سبيل المثال ان يكون هناك توفير
اربعه رحلات قطارات اضافيه مباشره من
اسوان الى القاهره لاستيعاب الكم الكبير
من السودانيين القادمين الى مصر حتى الان
هذا هو المشهد الابرز هي فكره ان يكون
هناك خروج اسرع ربما للسودانيين من خلال
هذا المع بر وهو ما تعمل عليه الدوله
المصريه التي تؤجل بان ربما لم يكن في
الحسبان ان يكون هناك توقع بهذا التكدس
الكبير للمواطنين بسبب الاحداث التي جرت
في السودان خلال الاسابيع الماضي كم يستمر
بقاء اللاجئين من السودان الى داخل مصر
عند الحدود احمد اذا كانت هناك يعني من
تقييمات او متوسط لعدد ساعات بقائهم في
هذا المعبر
امتى تروح يعني تتراوح الاحاديث من قبل ما
تحدثت منهم هناك من يتحدث عن يوم ونصف
هناك من يتحدث عن يومين يعني العطله تبدا
ربما من الجانب السوداني حيث ازدحام
الشديد في الجانب السوداني وايضا هناك من
يعني الاجراءات التي تتخذ في الجانب
المصري ايضا تستغرق بعض الوقت لخروج هذا
الكم من المواطنين
يعني كما ذكرت لك الاعداد كبيره بالفعل
هناك محاولات ان يكون هناك اولويات سواء
لكبار السن او لمرضى ولغيرهم ولكن ايضا
هناك بعض الاجراءات التي تتخذ بضروره
التامين الضمان من سلامه الاوراق سلامه
التوثيق ايضا من العمليات الجمارك
والتفتيش هناك الكثير من الحافلات التي
يجب ان تخضع جميعها للتفتيش التاكد من
هويات من يعمل من ياتون خصوصا في الرجال
على ضوء ما يعني تحدثنا عنه سابقا عن
ضروره ان يكون هناك تاكد كامل من هويه من
ياتون لعدم تسلل هي ضمان عدم تسلل ايا من
العناصر الارهابيه خصوصا مؤنث سنوات
العشره الماضيه منذ الاطاحه بحكم الاخوان
وكانت المعابر السودانيه او اللجوء الى
السودان برا احد السبل التي تمتزج اليها
اعراض الاخوان لتاريب عناصرها ورجالها
وبالتالي هناك رغبه لن يكون هناك استغلال
لهذا الوضع بعوده هذه العناصر مره اخرى
الى داخل الحدود المصريه اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل التي
نقلتها لنا من الحدود المصريه السودانيه
مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان
اذا وصلت الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في
جده السفينه العسكريه السعوديه الثامنه
والتي تحمل على متنها 180 شخصا من جنسيات
متعدده بعد اجلائهم من بورتسودان التفاصيل
مع زميلها نصفيان
مجددا العربيه مستمره في مواكبه وصول
السفن العسكريه وكذلك السفن التجاريه التي
تصل الى مدينه جده هنا هذه هي السفينه
السعوديه العسكريه الثامنه التي تصل في
هذه اللحظات وهي جلاله الملك الطائف وعلى
متنها اكثر من 180
شخص يحملون عده جنسيات طبعا للتو هذه
السفينه وصلت هذه اللحظه في قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده غرب السعوديه
تحدث اليوم عن اكثر من 96 جنسيه قامت
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه باجلاعهم
من
الى مدينتي جده هناك ايضا فرقاطات
عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي ونتحدث عن فرقاطات
ايضا عسكريه قبل هذه السفينه وصلت سفينتين
حربيتين صينيتين وتحميلان على متنهما اكثر
من 700 شخص من مواطني الصين وكذلك قبلها
في ساعات الصباح الاولى وصلت سفينه عسكريه
هنديه كانت تحمل قرابه
الثلاثه شخص من رعايه الهند وكل جميعهم
وصلوا الى مدينه جده
استعدادا
لعمليه مغادرتهم عبر مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي في مدينه جده
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن تنفيذها
عمليات اجلاء جديده في السودان مؤكده ان
عمليات الاجلاء شملت مواطنين فرنسيين
وكذلك مواطنين من بريطانيا والولايات
المتحده وكندا واثيوبيا وهولندا وايطاليا
والسويد كما اكدت ايضا انها قامت حتى الان
باجلاء
936 شخصا
حتى وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
الرعايه البريطانيه في السودان الى
الالتحاق بالرحلات الجويه دون تاخير مشيرا
ايضا الى ان بريطانيا قد لا تكون قادره
على مواصله عمليات الاجلاء عندما ينتهي
وقف اطلاق النار وقال كليبرلي ان الوقت
حان لتسريع تلك الجهود مشيرا الى نجاح
بريطانيا في اجلاء اكثر من 530 شخصا جوا
من السوداني حتى الان
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه ان الصين
ارسلت سفن قوتها البحريه الى السودان
لاجلاء رعاياها من اجل حمايه ارواح
وممتلكات المواطنين الصينيين وفقا المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الصينيه كيفي فهذا بان
الوضع الامني في السودان يتدهور بشكل
مستمر مع سعي دول عده الى اجلاء مواطنيها
عن طريق البحر او الجوي او البر
لقد بحثا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن الوضع في السودان مع رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي موسى فكي وقال المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ماثيو ميلر ان
بلينكن بحث مع رئيس المفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي التعاون من اجل وقف دائم للاعمال
العدائيه وانهاء القتال في السودان اتفق
الوزير بلينكن وفكي على ان ضغط قياده
الاتحاد الافريقي على القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع لا يزال
ضروريا لوقف فوري للعمليات العسكريه
والسماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه دون
عوائق
عبر عدد من طالبي الاجلال العربي عن
ارائهم ازاء الاجراءات والاوضاع الراهنه
وصلنا بصعوبه صعوبه لا يعني ما تنوصف يعني
قاعد نمشي على القتلى وصلنا هنا لكن ما في
يعني عشره يوم مرت علينا يمكن اكلين عيشه
وحده الاف او عشان ما يكون في مبالغه مئات
من السوريين موجودين في الخرطوم ما قادرين
يتحركوا اولا انعدام الامان ثانيا الغلاء
الموجود في بالنسبه للترحيل ثالثا
زي ما قلنا الشوارع ما كلها امنه يعني
خادم الحرمين الشريفين والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه بتساعد الناس لكن نطلب رجاء خاص
من برهان مين حمدي الله يهديكم ربنا
يهديكم يعني الشعب السوداني منتهي شعب
سوداني في شارع الجاليات في الشارع الناس
يعني يعني ما ممكن نفرين يتشاكلوا يضيعوا
الناس في النص
وصلت اليوم سابع طائرات الاجلاء التابعه
لسلاح الجو الاردني وعلى متنها 70 شخصا من
المواطنين وجنسيات عربيه واجنبيه من
الهيئات الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات الدوليه
واكد الناطق باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه سنان
المجالي ان بلده سيستمر بتقديم يد العون
للدول الصديقه وللرعايه الاردنيين في
السودان ممن لديهم الرغبه في الخروج في
الخروج من الاراضي السودانيه
يعني رحله كانت بر من الخرطوم لبورت سودان
عبر الامم المتحده اخذت تقريبا اربعين
ساعه بس الحمد لله انه يعني المملكه
الاردنيه يعني المبادره اللي عملوها
بشكروا عليها رحلتي من السودان من داخل
السودان صراحه كان في كثير مخاطر تعرضنا
لها لكن الحمد لله تيسرت والله كان الوضع
كتير صعب صعب كتير كتير يعني
فجاه صارت المشاكل وضرب ويعني قطعه
الكهرباء والمي
وعلينا كتير
منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل انفجرت الاوضاع
داخل السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مناطق جغرافيه متباعده في هذا البلد
الشاسع شمالا مشاهدينا في المروي في الوسط
في الخرطوم وفي الغرب في دارفور الان في
الاسبوع الثاني من هذه الاشتباكات يبدو
بان نقاط ونطاق هذه المواجهه الحاميه بين
الطرفين اصبحت اكثر تركيزا داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم اذا هذه العاصمه التي يقال عنها
مثلثه لماذا لانها تتكون من ثلاث تجمعات
سكانيه كما نتابع هنا الخرطوم بحري ام
درمان والخرطوم مدينه الخرطوم جنوبا يمكن
لنا ان نقول ان معظم الاشتباكات الدائره
الان في مدينه الخرطوم الجنوبيه تنحصر حول
نقطتين اساسيتين كما نشاهد هنا قياده
الولاده العامه للجيش السوداني والمطار
حول المطار هنا يقول الجيش السوداني بان
قوات الدعم السريع تسيطر على المطر اما
قياده الجيش القياده العامه فيسعى الطرفان
الان للسيطره عليها لماذا لان هذه النقطه
تعتبر استراتيجيه بمسار هذا النزاع الدائر
بين الطرفين اذا تنحصر المواجهه حول
المطار وحول القياده العامه حيث توجد
اشتباكات حاميه بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع في الخارج اما النقطه الثالثه
للاشتباكات فهي طبعا شرق المطار تقع
اشتباكات في حي الرياض كما نشاهد هنا كما
تقع اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه القصر
الجمهوري غربي المطار واشتباكات اخرى في
حي الصحافه وفي حي جبره وفي الكلا جنوب
غرب المطار اذا هذه خارطه الاشتباكات بهذه
النقطه اما مشاهدينا في ام درمان في ام
درمان غربي النيل توجد اشتباكات متفرقه
بين الطرفين اذا
تحديدا الاشتباكات تنحصر هنا حول مقر
الاذاعه والتلفزيون كما نشاهد هنا بهذه
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين هنا قوات
الدعم السريع تقول بانها تسيطر على هذه
النقطه وتسيطر على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون بينما يسيطر الجيش على محتوى
البث عبر محطه خارجيه اما النقطه الخامسه
فهي في الخرطوم بحري الوضع هنا هادئ قليلا
واهدئ طبعا من الخرطوم لكنه يبقى محتدما
وقبل يومين كما تابعنا خرج سجناء من هذه
النقطه تحديدا
هي سجن كوبر والذي يعتبر من اشهر السجون
واكبر السجون في الخرطوم بحري بعدما قالت
الشرطه انها اضطرت لفعل ذلك بسبب انقطاع
خدمات المياه والكهرباء التي طبعا انقطعت
منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني اذا مشاهدينا
كانت هذه ابرز نقاط المواجهه بين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني التي كما قلنا
انها تنحصر الان في داخل العاصمه بمحيط
القياده العامه القصر الجمهوري ونقاط اخرى
كما فصلها
كثيرا ما اصطدم السودانيون بمصطلح الجهه
الثالثه عند محاوله البحث عن المتسبب في
بعض من الاحداث التي مرت على البلاد حينها
كانت مختلف الاطراف ترمي التهمه على هذا
الطرف المجهول واليوم يعود هذا المصطلح
للواجهه فمن هي الجهه الثالثه
المواجهات تتكرر في السودان والمتهم واحد
قبل اسقاط الرئيس السابق عمر البشير قتل
متظاهرون مناوون له عام 2019 والقيت
التهمه على جهه ثالثه بحسب مدير المخابرات
انذاك صلاح عبد الله غوش
انتهى حكم البشير وبعد اشهر من التنازع
السياسي بين المكونين المدني والعسكري حدث
فضه اعتصام القياده ايضا تكرر قتل
المتظاهرين وشماعه التي تلقى عليها التهم
لم تتغير
في وقتنا الحاضر هذه الجهه الثالثه ايضا
هي المتهمه باداره النزاع اول وقوف وراء
النزاع العسكري الدائر وهي قوه او فلول
نظام البشير السابق طرف النزاع تبادل
الاتهامات وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو ان من
يدير الحرب على قواته هم قيادات في حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل حزب الرئيس السابق
عمر البشير واعتبر انهم من يقودون الجيش
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان رد
ايضا عبر العربيه مشيرا الى ان الجيش
السوداني وكاي جيش في العالم هدفه ضمان
وحده الدوله بشكل عام وليس العمل من اجل
شخص او جهه ما
[موسيقى]
اذا اكلت
نحن قوات مسلحه نعمل احترافيه وواجبنا
حمايه السودان حتى
معظم هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه باطل اريد فيها
الاتهامات ايضا صدرت من بعض القوى
السياسيه لاتباع النظام السابق بالوقوف
وراء نشوب الحرب واستمرارها ومحاوله
تصعيدها خاصه وان العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه هي التي اقصت حزب المؤتمر
وعلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يتداول
سودانيون ما يفيد بان انصار البشير يرفضون
صراحه قوات الدعم السريع لكنهم في ذات
الوقت يهددون بالوقوف بوجه الجيش حاله وقف
الحرب والهدف واحد مصلحه فلول البشير
العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات